Board. Okay, guys, welcome to officially welcome to our call
today. It is the beautiful month of October 29, two days away
from Halloween. We are almost in the second to last month before
this beautiful year ends. For some of you guys, that's a very
exciting thing, because you're gonna love to close the door on
this, this year. And some of you guys have had the year of your
life. And maybe that's not the case. But time is actually
flying. Lots happened this year, a lot of money's been made, a
lot of money's been lost, I'm sure. And here we are. That's
it's actually crazy. Also, I think I might have said this. But
guys, this is just a quick thing I want to say, get creative with
everything you're doing in your business, you need to let people
know what it is that you do. Porter, I told you what we're
doing for Halloween. No. So what we decided to do because one
of my friends, his father in law has this massive, actually an
orthodontist practice. So maybe you could take this to your
wife's family. But it's a great idea. So what they do every
single year on Halloween is instead of giving out candy, they
give out freaking toothbrushes branded with the company. And I
thought I was thought that was genius. Because think about this
500 1000 kids, they're they're dumping their brand in their
home and these toothbrushes are just floating around their house
for the next 365 days. So I was I was like, that's really,
really smart. So this year, because I keep saying I'm going
to do it, I keep saying I'm going to do it. This year, I
went ahead, and I made, like, to well, I don't think it was 650
of these things, I made $2,000 worth of Rubik's cubes, branded
with digital landlords. They're pretty dope, dude, they got the
digital landlord, they got the smiley, and we're gonna be
popping 650 Rubik's cubes into people's homes. And I'm hoping
that moms are going to trip on them. I'm hoping they're going
to end up in minivans. I'm hoping they're going to end up
at schools. And we're going to spread the gospel of rank and
rent. So just as a heads up, guys, you don't need to go spend
two grand, but get creative and think about opportunities. I got
650 little morons coming to my house. Just kidding. They're not
all morons. But a lot of these are pesky little kids. And
instead of giving them a Twix, that's going to just go go and
ruin their teeth, we're giving them a Rubik's cube, which is
going to get their minds sharp. And it's going to get the
branding floating through the southern Utah home. So anyway,
stoked about that. Unfortunately, I'm not going to
be there. So I got my son I'm hiring to pass those out. He's
going to forgive, forego the candy, make a little make a
little cheddar and hand those out since I'm in Dubai. But
guys, use opportunities that you see fit to talk about what
you're doing. Maybe it's a, you know, it's something in your
town, you can put a booth together. I see these all the
time. And I missed them. Like at my son's school, you can do
like a booth and you can give stuff away and whatever. And
they're just good opportunities to, to market your business
because there's a lot of money in your town. I don't even care
like, even where Porter's at, it's a population of like 3000
people or less, there is money in that town. In fact, I have a
client from that town, Mr. Porter. So I think you know who
that is. But anyway, so guys, today, we're gonna be talking
about how to almost get to 10k. Porter, why don't you go ahead
and share the story. And we are going to just get into this. Now,
from what I understand, technically, the deals not 100%
lost Porter sitting at $9400 per month, that is a gross nut
net, just so everybody knows. But he's at $9400 per month,
he's touched, he's almost touched the outer the outer rim
of the 10,000 multiple times, and he keeps falling a bit
short. So we're going to just rub it in a little bit Porter,
tell us what happened, where we're sitting, and what we can
expect from this deal. But
Okay, so I got I got one of this campaign going, it was in
fencing, because I got one in another one in fencing a little
while ago. So hold on, is this, would this be the first fencing
deal you've ever got?
No, this would be my second one.
So you have a client for fencing right now? Beautiful. Okay.
So I was like, I'm just gonna do the same thing. So I go into the
area, and the leads were not as heavily coming in as the first
one. So like, it took me a little bit to send this guy some
lead. But anyways, I called him. And it was the first guy I
called, it was, it was like, hey, someone's actually done
this with me before. And actually, it's someone in the
free group. It's fine. I like looked at his Facebook, and I
figured out who it was. But anyways, I figured out that he
had done this. But anyways,
Oh, tell me his name will kick him out right now.
Yeah. So he was, he didn't even tell me his name. But anyways, I
knew he, I knew who he was. So I started sending him like two to
three leads, whatever. And then I was like, hey, let's get on a
call. So I scheduled out for like the next day. And we get
on the call, I call him and I send him the zoom link, he
watches the screencast. I'm like, hey, get on the computer.
I'm trying to get this thing perfect as I can. Let's set up
like I'm making sure that he watches it. I watched my, my
screencast, make sure I included everything. And I sent it to him.
He watches it. And I'm like, sweet, I'm ready to go. And I'm
on my computer. I'm waiting. He called me. And he's like, Hey,
the zoom is not working. I'm like, Oh, my gosh. He's like,
yeah, I like I've been answering. And I'm like, Oh, my
gosh, like, for whatever reason, he couldn't figure out zoom. And
it was a Friday. And I was like, dude, I don't want to get this
half a call. So I just was like, well, let's just do it over the
phone. So this is where I think I messed up was I should have
waited until I got him on zoom. Because this is what happened is
we I did the call, I pitched him at two or 375 per month. And so
1500, which would have put you at 11,000, basically. Yeah. And
so like, it's perfect. So I pitched him at it. And he's like,
okay, that sounds good. I was like, am I supposed to be so
he's like, I think it's a master card. Like, oh, sweet. So I got
Yeah, I got him so I wrote his card number down. And then he's
like, I see the money on the car. Okay. So I'm like, okay,
whatever he's like, it's a car that I use them like, but now I
think about it's credit cards should be able to freaking charge.
Yeah, that was another car, or for he's on it. Yeah. I was like,
you're full crap anyway. But I didn't think about the, oh, I
got his number? Information? Whatever. So a day goes by, and
um, I keep texting like dude. Are you get the cars? Oh, sorry.
I haven't gotten there. And every day, it's like, why send
excuse, excuse. And then finally, it's so hard to get he won't
even answer my call. So I'm like, dude, this guy's dog. And
so I said, I was like, Hey, did you get my because I was like,
maybe I can just have him sign my agreement or my you know, my
credit card authorization so that I can just like sleep at
night, you know, knowing he signed it. So I send that over.
And he's like, you know, I haven't received it. So I sent a
screenshot of the credit card authorization at the bottom. I
said, he will be charged for 375 per month. And he reads it. And
he's like, wait, I thought it was $349 per month. And I was
like, I was like, what? So he literally he thought it was 349
per month. And so the price wasn't right. And it definitely
so he thought it was $1,500 for six months. So I'm like, dude,
what the hell do you mean? That is that is not right. So I
explained to him and he was on the fence about it. And I called
him last night, talked to him. And I was like, dude, like,
where are you at? And he wants to do it. And then at the end of
the day, he's just he's scared to make money scared to, you
know, spend the money. But anyway, I think the deal is
lost. I sent him a breakup text because I was tired of dealing
with him last night. I was like, dude, shit or get off the plot
because I wasted so much time the last couple days. So I just
didn't want to find somebody else.
It's a heartbreaker, bud. It's a heartbreaker. So all right. I'm
curious in the chat, who the heck has had something similar
to that to this happen to them? By the way, Gina Benson,
welcome to call. Good to see on I saw a few more people popping
in. Who has had something similar to this happened to
them in the in their entire career? Maybe they've only been
in the game a little bit and have had to happen. I've had
this happen, by the way, but this is far from uncommon. And
we're going to talk about this today. And yeah, that deal is
toast, but you go ahead and write that puppy off and go get
another one. It's heartbreaking because you don't want to have
to get another one, but you're gonna have to get another one.
And you just chalk it up to a lesson learned. You know what
I'm saying? But we are going to break this down today. But I am
curious in the chat. Has anyone had a similar experience? You
thought you had it? Oh, here we go. Get comments. I didn't even
see. Aaron Vogler says yes, yes, yes. With a triple quadruple
pack. Yes, he has. We got Jared Ochs has had a similar thing
happen twice in the last two weeks. Damn. But Porter, for
real, send me that guy's name. Kick him out of the group, block
him. And I'm going to see if I can get his account completely
span, removed from Facebook. Just kidding. Brandon Shulman.
Absolutely. Okay, so guys, this is a common thing. Porter, you
know, since you're my brother, I'm not gonna say you shouldn't
feel bad because you should, bro. You could have had the
frickin deal, dude. You know, but what it is. So let me start
off by saying this. This happens in any kind of sale
possible. The first time this ever happened to me, I'm not
going to go on story time forever. But you do need to
understand the very first time this ever happened to me in my
entire life. I was in Kearney, Nebraska. Yes, just like you say
Kearney is like when there's the fair, but it's spelled K E A R
N E Y could be an interesting city. Go check it out. It's
it might fit the the pop the the search volume on some of the
niches. Anyway, I mean, Kearney, Nebraska spring break 2013.
Instead of being in Miami trick and chasing women and doing all
that, I had a baby back home wife back home, and I was
knocking doors in the cold. So try that went on for size, but
I'm out in Kearney, Nebraska. And it's a Saturday, and I'm
trying to do my best. I'm trying to make money. It's I'm
frickin drove all the way there. And I, you know, I had a bunch
of deals teed up from Friday to Saturday, come back, come back,
come back, I'm going to do it. I'm going to do it. I'm too
young, too stupid to understand that people are full of crap and
they're liars, even though they're humans and they're
adult. So I'm waking up Saturday morning, stoked,
excited, listening to music, thinking I'm gonna have three
deals in the bag by lunch, and I'm going to sail into the
sunset on my way back home. And within about an hour, I realized
I'm gonna have to put on my frickin big boy panties and go
get a deal because all of those deals fell through. First one,
note on the door. Second one, no answer. Third one, don't know
where they're at. All the lights are closed, blinds are closed,
kids peeking through the frickin blinds like don't answer the
door. All of them done. So I'm knocking. I'm scrapping. And
guys, in my mind, I was like, if I have to drive, I don't even
know, it's like 12 hours from Kearney, Nebraska to St. George,
Utah, correction, Cedar City, Utah at the time, I am going to
die of, of, of just mental head heads, just jacked up because
I'm going to I'm going to have to go and think about how I
didn't get a deal on my last day. And I had the whole
Saturday. So I'm literally scrapping to the point where at
lunch, I told them not even to pick me up. I'm like, I have to
get a deal. So my manager came, he brought me like a Gatorade and
like a disgusting protein bar that I didn't eat. And I sat in
the car for five minutes and went knock. So I knock on the
store, guys from South Africa, I do my pitch, I get in the house,
I do the walkthrough. But I started skipping a few steps.
Like I remember, I didn't let him sit down at the table, like
all these little things kind of like Porter's talking about
where, you know, he didn't do the zoom call. Have I closed
deals before not been on a zoom call? Yes. Does it increase my
chances? Yes. But I kind of got a little bit lazy, because I
was so like, I was like Porter, like I had gotten deals almost
every day that week. And I was just so not desperate, but I was
so anxious to get a deal on Saturday, just like Porter so
anxious to finally cross that 10k mark. It's almost like you
have like this bad juju over your head. And I didn't I just
skipped a few steps and I didn't even let him sit down and I was
kind of rushing. Anyway, I pitched the deal. And he's super
interested in the thermostats because you can control them
from the phone. This is before Nest and everything. This is
very, very like high tech to everybody. And the guy's like,
he says to me, he's like, Well, hold on, like we get done. He
says yes, he gives me his information, like the deal is
done. And I'm filling out the card, just to call in and get
this thing set up. And he says to me, he goes, Hey, real quick,
just as a just a heads up. I have, you know, three
thermostats, not two. Will this work? Okay, or he says something
like that, or I've got this other kind of a system. Will
this work? And I hesitated just a tiny bit, because I didn't
want to lie to the guy, but I never heard this question. I was
like, Yeah, it should. There should be no issues. I like,
yeah, I don't think there's any problem. I said, let me just call
my manager really quick. And I'm gonna let me just double
checks. I really didn't want to like, lie to him or whatever.
Anyway, I think I just text my manager and I was like, Hey, can
you do this? And he was also trying to get deals and he
didn't respond. And I was like, Hey, he hasn't responded. But I'm
telling you, if this doesn't work, then we can just lower
your price, whatever. But I'm 90% sure that's gonna work. Well,
90% was not good enough for him. 90% was enough for him to feel
a little bit hesitant, a little bit queasy about the deal. And
from there, I just lost him. And he's like, Well, you know, I
had this meeting, I'm going to go check the meeting out, you
get the answer, come back, meet me, and then we'll do the deal.
But I really want to get that 100% answer. I don't want to
maybe I don't want to whatever. And the so long story short, I
lost the deal. The other crappy part is I found out that yes,
indeed, that I didn't lie, it did do that thing that I that he
did do three thermostats, whatever. And the lesson that I
learned, and it sucked, because I actually left the house, you
know, went and tried to get another deal. And I came back
thinking, Oh, thank goodness, this guy's gonna be home, and
I'm gonna be able to get this deal. And I got back and met
him there telling me, you know what, I thought about it more.
And this isn't something that I need right now, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah. So basically, the same exact story that you
have, but in alarms, and I've had this happen so many times
to me, we're doing rank and rent that I'm sick and tired of
even thinking about it. So this is something that happens. But
yeah, let's let's break this thing down, guys. Where do you
guys think Porter went wrong? Porter, where do you think you
went wrong? You think you went wrong, not getting on the zoom?
Or where do you think that we lost this deal? Because I'm
telling you right now, I don't think the guy was confused about
375 per week. I think that was just an excuse. I think he
definitely knew what it was. I think that he came back and that
was just him trying to save face based on what you're telling me.
But what do you think you wrote? You went wrong, bud.
I think definitely the zoom call I this is this is what pissed
me off too, though, as he closed one of the deals. So I was like,
bro, and that's why I told him, I said, did you close one of
these jobs? I sent you like, you're telling me like, I don't
see you three. So I didn't think that was a problem. I feel like
I said enough to be the sender screencast. The only thing that
I didn't do was get I get them on the zoom call. And I
obviously I didn't make sure that the deal went through on
the call. You know what I'm saying? Like, I didn't feel like
I actually like got a yes or no. And I should have just said,
hey, if it's a yes, it's either yes or no, it may be is a no.
And I shouldn't have let him freaking get off. I should have
just, you know.
So let me ask you a question. Let's dissect this a little
bit. You said in three leads over the course of how many how
many days weeks? How many leads? Yeah,
it was like one. It was like a week.
Okay, so every week three leads. Did he close? Which one of the
three leads he closed number one, two or three?
Number three, the third one,
the third one. And that's when you decided to go for that's
that's textbook. Good job, by the way, because you don't need
to send him five if he closed number three. So you did all
that correctly. You sent him the screencast did. Yeah, the only
thing guys, remember that when you lose a deal when you lose a
sale, most of the time, it's the step previous. So you think, oh,
you know, I didn't do a good job in the presentation. And that's
why I lost the deal. But really, it's typically something if you
lost the deal there, it's probably something in the
previous step, which is the setup. And I mean, I think
there's two things that could have happened. I think number
one is, you know, guys, I ran calls trying to close deals on
the phone for four years. I isn't it's crazy. Porter, did
you know that I didn't start doing zoom closes until 2020?
I did not. It's so hard. I was getting so frustrated.
Now there. Let me say this. I when I say I didn't I didn't
do them like consistently once in a while I would but it was a
little bit more comfortable for me because I felt a little bit
like nervous having to sit in front of a screen and talk to a
human even though it was a computer screen. So I was the
one that was opting usually for the phone call I'd get my card
is kind of like a de stress or I could talk and whatever. But
guys, I for the first first four years of my rank and rank
career, I did not use zoom. And then the only reason I started
using zoom is because it was COVID and everyone is talking
about zoom. And there was like all these memes on zoom and
people doing weird stuff during classes and calls and stuff. And
I was like, and everyone was like zoom, zoom, zoom. So I was
like, Okay, I'm gonna start using it. And then I just shot
through the roof. And I was like, I'm an idiot. Because it's
just like being in person to the point that even if I was closing
somebody in Dubai, and they want to go to dinner, I would choose
to do is I go to dinner, I choose to do to do a zoom call
to close the deal because I can show them things. People are
serious when they're at their desk at their computer. But
that's number one, guys, always, always, always, always, always
get on a zoom call. Now, I'm at the same time, because this is
an art not a science. You know, sometimes you you try so hard to
get on a zoom call that you miss the deal, you miss the energy
and whatever. And so I will say there are times when conditions
can't be perfect. But dude, I would rather even someone be on
a zoom call in a gas station parking lot on their phone,
than be on a phone call, because you ended up running a phone
call, correct? Yeah. Yeah. So that I would say that's number
one. And then the second thing, and it's something I want to
talk about really quick, too. And by the way, Brandon said,
well, let's look at our comments here. Aaron said, Yeah, hopping
on a zoom, probably would have built more trust seems like that
was the issue. I agree with you, Aaron. And that is one of the
things, I would say the hardest thing here, sending the leads
does help build trust. But when people can see you, they can see
this is a real person. And if they have my credit card,
they're actually not going to like scam me. That helps a lot. I
agree. And then Brandon says, what if you would have
compromised said, let's do it for 349 per week for a month or
two, and then it will go to 375. So Brandon, just a little
clarification. The guy's claiming that he thought it was
$349 per month, instead of per week. So it's not a discrepancy
of 15 or $25. It does discrepancy of 1200 $1,100 of
difference per month. So the guy's basically, in my mind,
full of crap. And saying that he thought it was something else
when I think that's bullcrap. What do you think, Porter?
No, now, after I'm done with this, everything that I'm
thinking about, I'm like, that's so dumb. Like, I showed you the
screencast, like everything that I was pointing at, like, I
didn't drop the price. But during the call, I clearly said,
Hey, $1,500 per month, like, I was not hesitant about that. I'm
like, you, you're, you're, you're full of crap.
Yeah, you can't I mean, it's it did he ever sign the contract?
No. Okay. So yeah, he definitely knew. Here's the other thing
guys. And this is another really, really important thing
is I have a live Aaron, if you're still on this call, I
would love for you to pull this up. And maybe we can reference
it in the comments. But there's a live we have it's called drill
the hole. And there it is so important that you guys getting
a credit card. unbelievably important. You did a great job
because a lot of people say, Hey, call me and I'll give you
my credit card digits. And that's great. But running the
credit card is the key. Okay. And so I have this live, I don't
want to like spoil it. But basically, there was something I
used to do in door to door sales, a lot of the stuff that
I that I learned, that's like the fundamental stuff about
sales, I learned from door to door sales, but it's exactly
the same here. And what I would find guys is that when I got a
deal, I'd close somebody on getting an alarm that was going
to be in their house for the next however many years, five
year contract, I would get the credit, I'd get the credit card,
I'd get the check, I would get the contract signed everything
right, just like Porter did. But sometimes like we would always
try to schedule by the way, we would always try to schedule to
get these things scheduled right away. So if I close you today,
like right now, I would have it scheduled tonight, because I
knew that if I didn't, there was a good chance that you were
going to cancel. Okay, that's just what happened because you
start thinking about it. And it was emotional sale. Oh, man, five
50 bucks a month or whatever that's $600 a year, or more, we
could do something else that but then what I started realizing
is that if I could just get some of the equipment in the house,
even one piece of equipment and charge their card charge their
bank account for that initial deposit, even if it was $100, I
almost never lost any deals, I swear to you, and my technicians
would get really pissed off because they wanted to get to
the house, install the whole thing and not have to come back.
So I'd have to text the technicians and be like, yo, this
lady is not going to be cool with you staying in her house
till midnight. She's a single lady. And you look pretty scary
and you haven't showered in like a year. But I'm going to pay
you whatever 100 bucks or not probably 20 bucks that time
said it wasn't making 100 bucks to throw around. I'll pay you
20 bucks, come in, drill a hole in the wall, slap up the panel
and come back tomorrow, I'll pay you extra for your time spent.
And just because guys, it was crazy the amount because then
guess what it was real to them. They could see it on the wall.
And most importantly, we had charged the card and the damage
was done. There was no going back even though it was possible
to get their money back. It was so much harder. So what I highly,
highly, highly, highly recommend by the way, Aaron just
referenced it, that is a phenomenal live and it is very
true. And we do this the same with anything that we sell, we
sell is get a payment, send the guy an invoice, say, Hey,
Porter, what I would have done, hey, I'm gonna send you an
invoice, you can put the money on later, but I got to get at
least like $100 down payment, non refundable. And I'm going to
send it to you real quick. And then I'll charge the rest of it,
you know, let's say in 24 hours, but I'm going to charge 100
bucks. So hang on one second. I promise you if you would have
charged even 100 bucks, there would have been an 80. I'm just
throwing numbers out here. But maybe, you know, 80% chance he
would not have went sideways on you.
No, it pisses me off so bad because I was like this thoughts
and you said yes.
Yeah, and that's the frustrating part. And I you know,
Francesca's lost deals like this, Kyle's lost deals like
this, I've lost deals like this. And I'm hoping that people on
this call are not going to lose deals like this guys, if you get
the deal, make sure you frickin run the deal on the call. Okay,
and good. Look, I understand the situations people are lying.
We've had the craziest stuff happen. We've had people giving
the credit card, and they're reading all the digits and they
get to the last four and they cut the zoom and they pretend
that their phone died and you never hear from them again.
We had a guy just barely this is so amazing. We had a guy in
the last couple weeks, about a month ago, get done, we figure
it out, put a deal together. He's pumped. This guy has been
hitting me up for years about doing this. And anyway, long
story short, he gets the credit card information to us. And he
tells Kyle, he's like, Yeah, I'm sorry, he doesn't give the
credit card information. He's a yes, he's I'm good. He's a
whatever. And then you know what he says? He says, I lost my
wallet. Let me I'm gonna have to find it. And then I'll let you
know. It's like, bro, no one lost their wallet. And I don't
know about you. But I have like 15 cards saved on my computer.
And I know my card. And I've got a picture of my card, and all
this different stuff. And dude, Kyle, Kyle, Kyle took the bait,
dude. Kyle took the bait called me got the deal. We got the
deal. Didn't run the deal. I was like, yeah, things done, dude.
Guess what, dude still hasn't done it.
In two weeks.
Oh, it's been like a month. And then we finally got a text back.
We started giving him a hard time. We're like, Hey, bro, are
you like, you know, not sure that you can make this work? Or
are you? Do we need to talk to your wife? Like, it's somebody
that's like pretty chill. We're giving him a hard time. And that
was like, finally, like, oh, sorry, been busy. We had a baby
and I can't make any decisions to after the baby. And it's
like, bro, you already said yes, you said you lost your wallet.
So point is, guys, I don't care if these by the way, Richard
Marches, welcome to the call, my friend, it doesn't matter how
old people are doesn't matter if they're men, women, doctors,
lawyers, frickin, whatever people are full of schnazzle.
And they will lie straight through their teeth while
looking you in the eyes and eating frickin, whatever. That's
just how people are. Do not leave the call. First of all,
always get on a zoom call every single time. Let's talk about
that really good Porter. I couldn't get on the zoom call you
said because he had an Android. Is that a thing? Because he
should know.
I think I was that was complete bull crap. I think he didn't want
to get on the zoom call because he was he was out on a job. I
told him I said, Hey, I need a computer. That was his first
thing I told him I said be on a computer. He was that was this
one thing. And then zoom I called him I was like, we're like,
are you home? He's like, no, I'm out on a job. I'm like, okay,
well, that sucks. Like, so now he's in his truck. And then the
zoom call, which I think you can join zoom, just join in your
browser. So I'm like, I don't think he just wanted to get on
zoom. He was just making that excuse.
100%. So here's the thing, guys, is if I'm doing a call, and I've
tried to get this deal, and the guy closed a job, and I'm like,
hey, look, this guy's hot, let me get on it, whatever. And I, I
could see and I could I could justify like, all right, you
know, perfect scenario, he's at a computer, and he's on zoom. I
could justify though, getting on a zoom on your phone on the job
site, I'd say, hey, can you go in your truck? Let's talk like
that's still not ideal. But it's it's it works. And I've closed
deals like that. But I would rather wait, I would I would
literally tell the guy maybe on the spot, something like, hey, I
you know, no disrespect here. I've sent you three leads, you
already made money. You said you'd be on a zoom call, I need
you to be on a zoom so I can show this to you. Can I like, if
it's not that I need you to be by computer in the next couple
hours, I probably would never get on a call call on without
being in zoom, unless maybe I had tried two, three times. And
I was like, at this point, I'm just losing that momentum, that
steam that energy that whatever, that's when I might justify
that. But I would say it's, it's, you could justify getting
on a zoom on the phone, but definitely make sure you get on
a zoom, even if it's a gas station parking lot on a on a
job site zoom for sure, because it's just hard. Like if, you
know, people, it's, again, when we go back to door to door
sales, guys, there's these little things that the more of
it's, it's like the training, right? Sales is like baking a
cake, we have the perfect recipe, we're telling you exactly
when to put in the flour, when to bake, when to, you know, stir
the eggs, when to add this, how much butter, what brand of
butter, whatever. And, you know, you guys can, you know,
you have to do it perfectly. And you might still have a cake
that's that works, right? But the less of the of the
recommendations, the more you deviate from the exact recipe,
the more variables there are, and the more chance you have of
losing the deal of the cake coming out tasting like garbage,
right? So you do what you can, you know, once in a while, you're
like, all right, ideally, you're supposed to use this kind of
butter. But today, we only have this kind of butter. It's not
perfect. But you know what, we need the cake because it's
somebody's birthday, I'm going to slam it in. That's a good
that's something that you could look past. Something like not
getting on a zoom call. That's like, you know, using baking
powder instead of flour. Like that's tough, right? And yes,
maybe once in a while, you're going to squeak out a deal. But
I'm telling you guys right now, we're gonna we're talking about
this, because it's just for everybody to not lose this, make
sure you guys get on a zoom call every single freaking time,
even if it's in a gas station parking lot, even if it's on a
job site, and just tell the business owner, especially
Porter, you had enough leverage because he you'd you'd send him
three leads and he closed one you had made him money without
anything in return. So I think it would have been completely
fine for you to say like, look, dude, you told me to be on a
call. I need you to like get to a truck and get on a zoom you
sir, you have to push a link. I've done this 100 times. I don't
care if you have an iPad, you just push the link and it's
gonna put you on pretty simple. My grandpa does. Yeah, you can
joke about it. But get on a zoom. Yeah. Okay, so it's okay,
bro. Um, nothing like losing nothing like losing a $18,000 a
year, but could have been pretty nice to when you think about
it like that. It makes you sick, right? Yeah. Dude, I I've been
to the very, very end of deals and been like, I literally did
all this work. It's been it's been weeks of work. And I just
lost at the very end because I was lazy or because I said this
or because I did that. And it's frustrating. Okay. So Trevor
time says not being able to get a zoom call from an Android is
100% BS. Yes, that is absolutely true. Because guys, all you have
to do is click on it. Yes, we know that I enjoy is our
inferior. Just kidding to you Android users. To be honest, I
just think that Apple's got me by the teeth. But you can just
click on a link. And Aaron says, Yeah, someone needs to tell zoom
to get compatible with Android lol. Okay, Corey says, Are there
any live recordings of zoom calls with past customers that
we can? Yes, there are. Corey Gilbert. Yes, there are. Maybe
Aaron, you could tag him in a few. We have a few live calls
that I've done. These are some of the OG calls from 2020. You're
going to see that my process isn't perfect. I'm still
learning. But you definitely can see that I'm a young buck, just
trying to make a name for himself back in the the on the
interwebs. Gina Benson says, What do you think about recording
a video to send to the business owner before getting on the
zoom? Yeah, I do that. I don't know. Maybe Gina's talking
about said like having one video that you can send that could be
a good idea. That's a really good idea. And I'm guessing
part of you said in the zoom that like kind of explained what
the expectations were before, right? Yeah, screencast. Sorry.
What do you think about recording a video to send the
business owner before getting on the zoom? Yeah. So yeah, I'm not
really sure you're saying Gina, but if you're saying because
that is actually a really good idea. I like to do with lead
generation deals, I really like to have, I'll take the time to
manually create a custom video, a custom screen recording a
custom screencast for each one, because then I can say their
name again, and again, and again, I can show their website,
it's very custom, and it's 10 minutes long, five minutes long.
However, with those of you, all of you that are on this call
that joined digital landlords, we do the same thing, we have a
call that kind of sets expectations. It's funny, we do
the exact same process that we teach with you guys, when you
join this program, right, we send you a screencast, it's not
exactly customized for every single person. But that
screencast says, here's the expectations. You know, when you
get to the end, don't don't tell us you need to do this, this,
this or this, like, we are expecting you to give us a yes
or no, if it's a maybe it's a no. And we're going to get on and
show you this, this and this. And we're going to ask you to
make a decision, like, we do the exact same thing. So that's a
good idea. Let's see, Gina says, yeah, like custom for each
one. Yeah, that's, that's what I that's what I do. That's exactly
what I do. Aaron says, Andy, the you can't sell an Android
user truth lives on. It is a little more difficult. I sold
Android users, but I know what you're saying, bro. Okay, Aaron
says to Corey, he's gonna message a few screencasts Nick
has done for real profit. Also, Corey, if you want, like, I'm
going to check this out. Like if I, if you go to, if you just go
to the Facebook group, I'm going to see what the smart search
I'm just I have no idea how I'm even going to find it. I'm going
to go to the Facebook group, I'm going to go to the little
search bar and put live recording. Hold on. Maybe live
sales call. Okay, there's Yeah, right there. Okay, that's let's
see. Hold on. There we go. I got one right there. Oh, that's a
discovery call. Just kidding. But yeah, another thing that you
guys can do it, Corey is you can just do some smart searches might
take you a second. But if you don't want to wait for anyone,
look, there's another one right there. Borhan, one of our
students actually posted his deal. There's a bunch of them
just type in smart searches, live recording, live call. I'm
going to I bet you type if you type in live close, like this
live close Nick would inside of the group search bar. There we
go. Boom, found one right there. There's a there's a deal that I
lost right there on December 7 2022. If you want to see that
one, there is let's see, I bet I can find another one quickly.
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold tight. See if I can find
another one. There's a picture of Kanye in a boat. You guys
know what I'm saying? That's great. Let's see. Oh, right
there. There's another one. Yeah, anyway, that's just another
idea, guys. Video two of to build your list. Just go do a
couple smart searches. But Aaron, yeah, that would be cool
if you could if you could help him out as well just to kind of
speed things up. Okay. I'm just gonna see if there's one more.
Dude, I by the way, guys, for those of you that have been in
this group. Oh, here we go. I'm gonna here's a $1,200 a month
flat fee close. Corey, I'm gonna tag you in this one right now
just to save Aaron some time. But just guys. Yeah, that's one
thing to know in this group. That's the beautiful thing about
Facebook groups, even though I freaking hate Facebook sometimes
is if you just go in and search for certain things like Oh, what
would Nick probably have done live clothes live this just
type in Nick would and whatever you can find a lot of material
this group is almost three years old and it's chock full of
material. Okay. So anyway, just tagged you, bro.
Your clothes on the guy in St. George the excavation guy right
before my first deal. I watched that the night before just to
get a good feel.
Oh, yeah, dude, it's it you know what I used to do every single
day before I hit the doors. I would listen I there was the
guys the top guys making the most amount of money. They had
their pitches recorded and they were put in like our company
training. And I promise you, I would listen like a 20 minute
video. I would listen to Oz making my omelet. I would listen
to it as I get in the shower. I listen to every freaking day. And
you know, it was amazing. I would get on the doors, I would
get at a closing table, somebody would say something and I would
just say this one liner. And it was like exactly like, you know,
this there's this guy named Jordan Williams, it was like one
of the OGs and he had like 400 accounts made how many $100,000
as like a college kid selling selling alarm systems. And I
would say the exact same lines the exact same ways that he
would. And it was like, okay, I'm like programming my
subconscious. So guys, I'm not saying I'm the only person knows
how to close deals. But I scaled quickly we went we were closing
every freaking deal we were on fire. And if you guys want to go
to my 2020 calls, we have probably four or five that you
can listen to. Definitely guys listen to those go to the gym
before your freaking your zoom call. And and listen to that. I
know it's maybe you don't want to maybe you can get on the
treadmill, whatever and just you're going to start hearing and
saying things that I say how I explain the monopoly thing how
I explain this how I explain that the confidence that I have
when I go for the close and help Corey, Corey Gilbert knows
exactly who Jordan Williams is. That's hilarious. Because he
also did door to door. Okay, let's see. Shane Coogan can also
have the screencast. Yes. So they're not screencast. These
are actually recordings. Corey, since you're on this call, so I
just tagged you if you could hook Shane up real quick and tag
Shane on that video as well. That might push it to the top.
But guys, these are these are not record. These are just
recordings. They're not screencasts of me doing live
closes. Okay. Gina says you're gonna check it out. Oh, there we
go. Aaron just barely had went ahead and posted for us. So
guys, in the next 12 minutes, let's let's see what what
questions you guys have. What? This could be about sales, this
could be about losing deals, closing deals, get a 10k. Any
question you have drop in the chat and that what I'm going to
ask you Porter is what have you learned on this journey of
scrapping your way to $10,000 because it has been a scrap
Porter, he went he got to do I think you got to like 85 one
time. Yeah. And then you got busy with farming, which is
natural, you dump some of your business owners weren't super
solid, you lost a couple deals. There was that like you almost
touched it then I think you're at nine and then you dropped and
then you you like turn it back on you're at 9400 and you almost
just had 10,000 you're gonna get 10,000 obviously but like
now you're like give us what have you learned just trying to
hit that 10,000 it's almost like you got this like dark cloud of
doom hanging over your head you're like oh my gosh, I'm not
sure if I can hit it you obviously can but it's sometimes
it's like when you want something so bad. It's like so
hard to hit but yeah, tell us about that.
I honestly even with the last couple deals that I've gotten I
tried to have a different mindset of getting these deals
like instead of like like that 10k is such a big number which I
know I mean it's a lot of money but like in the grand scheme of
things it's not but like to me I've always made it this huge
deal and I feel like it's like psyching me out a little bit you
know I'm saying like I'm this close but then like I make the
zoom call too much pressure like I'm forcing it too much and
like the last couple deals I was like hey if I get to 10k and
because the goal was hey I want to get to 10k and it wasn't even
to get to 10k before I was on farming but like it kind of
worked out that way because I was landing a couple deals and
then I was like dude I gotta hit this like I want to hit it this
month like I was setting goals and we were like trying to get
these things happening and I think I had sales breath I really
do think at the end of the day I should have just been like hey
the goal is 25,000 and when I hit that 20 that hit that 10k
great but like I got to kind of you know I felt like that I was
almost like my end point in my head mentally you know I'm
saying like I just over over hyped it in a way that I kind of
just psyched myself out maybe I was just a little bit too
salesy on the call you know like I was forcing it you know but I
definitely feel like the deals are never perfect every one of
my deals I always expect them to be perfect but every one of
them are are wrong in some way but I end up getting them so
like that's the crazy thing like I'm literally doing prospecting
calls on the tractor I'm like standing over leads with
servando in the background chopping his gum you know I'm
saying like there's there's certain certain things that are
happening but like just you're able to get the deal nothing
needs to be perfect to do it yeah that's a good point I hope
everyone knows that well by the way you're going to get it you
just kind of relax you got to I think what you need to do is set
your targets be like dude I got to get to 25k because I'm
playing small ball and then 10k is just something you got to
pass to get to 20k I think you're making 10k too big of a
deal 10k is not any money dude you you can't do dog diddly
whack on 10k a month and I mean that disrespectfully I just mean
that like if you have that mentality it's like yeah 10k is
just on my way to 50k 10k is on my way to 100k it's just a
little blip in the grand scheme of things honestly the best
money you're ever going to make guys for those of you that
haven't is your very first dollar doing this because that's
going to hit I promise you the hundred dollars I made on the
golf course back in 2018 2017 whatever it was I'm sorry I made
I got my my towing deal back in 2016 because I kind of have two
different in my mind I kind of started twice I started in 2016
I took a break I came back into it but my towing deal for 600
bucks a month and my hundred dollars that I made when I got
back into the game those two payments were sweeter I promise
you this isn't sounds to sound cooler to sound whatever those
are worse sweeter deals those meant more to me those felt more
euphoric than when I made a million dollars and I made one
point five when I made a hundred thousand dollars in a day like
I've done some really cool stuff financially not crazy crazy
but like some cool stuff that I thought was really cool that
hundred dollars when I was on the golf course meant everything
to me but you just have to like set yeah dude 2010,000 nothing
we're gonna get to 50 we're gonna get to 100 but I do
understand what you're saying is sometimes you do have sales
breath so yeah just relax realize you're going to 25
anyway this is just a blip in the radar so what was the other
thing I was gonna say on that note oh I was gonna say this I
like what I love I like love whatever is guys Porter's been
able to do this while doing something entirely different so
his entire summer okay let's let's talk about this early
summer like March April right when we got back from Africa you
got right back into working with dads that was let's say March
April May June July August September October October so the
last eight months okay you've been full time farming okay what
were you at when you got back from Africa in in March how
much were you making per month because I know you had some
deals and you lost some deals were you like six no I think I
was at 45 45 or something well no it might have been 64 think
it was 64 okay point being is that Porter has been able to
maintain his deals by the way he got to six last year while
doing farming but my point is that he's been able to not only
keep his clients but add another $3,000 per month while he's been
working for you know with my dad to learn the ropes of the farm
and this is like very strenuous work sometimes 12 hours a day
sometimes 12 hours a day take a nap go back and work throughout
the night to try and get the hay baled and make sure it doesn't
get rained on sometimes work in 20 hours out of 24 hours and he's
still been able to do it and and sometimes he's taking calls
while he's on the tractor and some of you guys I promise you
would be like oh my gosh it's loud and the business owner it's
not going to be professional and I'm going to wait until I'm off
the tractor or he's got you know we have this guy that works for
my dad that he swear he chews gum louder than anyone on this
planet and you definitely would think you'd lose the deal if you
were doing that next to him and he's just doing it and the point
I'm trying to make guys is that some of you guys are so worried
about everything being perfect that you are not taking any
action and I'm telling you I would rather you like Porter have
you ever had a situation where somebody's like yeah I'm not
going to do it because you don't sound professional no nobody
cares dude a lead to lead is a lead I don't care what you're
doing in the background like yeah okay ideally it's quiet
whatever but at least like you being on the farm it's being
real it's being raw so anyway just want to point that out guys
for those of you that have excuses like I don't have time
I'm busy I got kids also on top of that Porter's wife's been
pregnant the entire time so she's been he's been you know
helping her with that and then also they just had a child was
it like three weeks ago yeah yeah three weeks ago Porter had a
child so I just want to point this guy out guys he's been
able to get to 10k over the last two years while doing
something full time that he's going to do for the rest of his
life while his wife's been pregnant they had a baby we've
also moved to Africa he was there for a month like we've
done all this stuff there is time you can do it it's just
about prioritizing so yeah that's it Porter when are we
going to hit 10k dude what are we doing here we're going to
keep that same that same location and we're going to go
get another business owner what's the plan well the goal is
I got to get well I'm going to get another city going I'm
going to have one in the works my problem is I've been I'm not
as prepared so I've had a few weeks where I'm like it's slow
because I don't have one ready to go so I'm going to have one
more ready to go I'm going to let this one sit at the lead
because I'm getting leads it's just been a little bit slower
so I don't want to bag the area completely because I who
literally was the first guy called so I'm going to keep him
I'm going to hook a guy today and I like by the end of the
week I should either be on as it well what is today what
Tuesday by the end of the week hopefully I at least have a
zoom call scheduled or send them enough leads for the
beginning of next week but I'm so close dude I'm so close
you'll get it we're just going to get it and then once he gets
he gets it we'll figure out what he learned by actually
getting the deal but yeah um just go ahead and call that one
quits did he say yeah we're done we're not doing it for sure
no I said the breakup text I saw that he read it but no reply
so I'm just kind of I would just send him a text like best
of luck man yeah like you know what I'm saying like uh the dude's
not doing it and then sometimes that will like get the deal
back that'll get you that control but anyway lesson learned
you know eighteen thousand dollar lesson learned no big deal
just simple anyway guys it happens it's business it's just
better than eighteen thousand dollar lesson than a million
dollar lesson that's the way I look at it and again it's crazy
that we're even talking in these kind of numbers that you
can go out and get a fifteen hundred dollar per month deal
from a skill set that Porter didn't even know how to do two
years ago while he's driving the tractor while he's having
kids while he's freaking doing all this other stuff that's
amazing and Kyle Patton thanks for hopping on at the end of the
call bud all right Porter I'm out see you guys thanks for